the only way I could look more like a
tourist is if I was wearing a fanny pack
well it's too late for me you can still
travel good as gold so today at American
Express Studios we're showing you a few
quick ways to travel foreign land it's
not a data plan lots of people think the
second you go abroad this thing becomes
a camera with a clock on it not true
there are a bunch of map apps to let
your phone uses GPS figure out where you
are on google maps just pull up each
destination before you leave and save it
to more helpful words screenshots screen
grab everything reservations boarding
passes even receipts between Matt and
your stealth maps will be good as gold
wherever the journey takes you
gotta travel tip you live by tell us
about it in the comments